herman excuses aujourd'hui on se
retrouve sur déjà dans ce bureau est
aussi sûr sinon voilà on est de retour
en france les alpes tout ça on va skier
tutorial teint une première étoile ou ce
qui tu fais pas chier on va quand même
le faire dans le doute s'il te plaît
c'est passionnant retour télé on peut
skier [ __ ] au cou [ __ ] avait lancé
alors là mon gars là notre étoile d'or
du break avec b huawei le slow down ces
problèmes ok c'est parti oui à plusieurs
pistes en c1 2-1 mais nous à la montagne
basique genres et les halles aujourd'hui
on passe notre flocons une autre étoile
d'or n'y a pas de transition entre les
deux ça c'est un homme qui veut du ski
qui veulent la folie liés aux sur la
tête ça marche par tn figure mois que
j'ai appris dans le jargon s'appelle
orange black s'est passé au dessus un
truc orange mois la tendance et faire du
ski doo de gorge le caillou les gens
avaient vu d'aussi près le caillou petit
orange grindat on a inventé une figure
un pas se mentir ce quiz et moniteurs
saillé nouveau métier alors là mais je
crois qu'ils aient un saut énorme
attention
yachvili asus uni droite de merde
ben là où lyon l'aube itx yolo beach de
retour avec mon poto le caillou alors là
c'est faux c'est faux pires figures du
monde ouais ça c'était d'un mec qui sait
qu'il va décéder la piste on s'en bat
les couilles oyolos quechua faire [ __ ]
moi je me suis je veux skier sur la tête
m avec cette [ __ ] à renaître ce gars
quoi garder leur envoya le démon des
pistes qui rentra d'aller dans son corps
pour l'exorciser s'il vous plaît ok on
va faire deux trois grind un peu
farfelue ça veut rien dire on va prendre
aussi parce qu'on n'est pas assez bon
avec ce qu'on a la voix la sombre est un
[ __ ] de rouleau à pâtisserie il doit
faire une pâte avec ça mon gars ok ok je
trouve un petit coin je trouve un petit
coin sympa un petit coin à planer une
fille la barre en car regardez regardez
regardez bon à la haye ce qu'on n'a pas
envie d'amener quelqu'un ici tu vois tu
la mets dit si tu lui fais l on songe ou
en bas tu pars comme ça ben là tu crois
[ __ ] de cailloux des morts et a fini
sa vie avec un autre homme mieux que toi
un homme qui veut aller très très vite
alors là on est au mois de mai le ski
mais arrêtez ont fini comme çà c'est
charmant si regardez moi je vois
quelqu'un faire une piste au noir comme
ça mais je le respecte éternellement
personne ne me dira quoi faire et où
aller dans ma vie c'est ma vie et on n'a
qu'une vie alors je prendrai les
décisions qui me correspond le plus
oh là là voilà à l'e3 côte en moi
j'aurais bien fait d'écouter ma mère ou
si je me froid mais c'est une blague
le responsable de ces pistes impute un
[ __ ] il est une fine couche de neige
sur des sur les cailloux ce qui fait
qu'ils croient que ceux des bosses et
u17 devant annabelle sa copine on y va à
reculons aller la position vitesse à
reculons ça va être une violence face au
non ça c'est la beauce piège ça rien
c'est pour toi à la bella pansements moi
quand je laisse aux skis c'est comme ça
ah ah ben là où tu n'as pas car je m'en
bats les couilles en petit couteau moi
c'était plus beau grec en effet je sais
pas ce que je fais a trop vite
l'homme le plus reste du monde comme
elles sont ce qui est moins raide [ __ ]
j invente un nouveau sport le so2 et au
ski je sais qu'on peut le faire chez
qu'on peut y arriver
pourquoi fois j'ai vu un mec sauté de là
où il est mort vous avez des amis qui
sort des anecdotes comme ça le slide
alors là on gagne les compétitions va
pas se leurrer un cautionne une caution
pour les skis à la blague d'appeler
s'amuse je détecte du skill oppermann
voilà alors ça le coup ok le coût du
grade et à l'horizontale en mangeant de
la neige personnes s'est fermement tepa
même ton père quelle étoile dont il sait
pas le faire quelle est cette trempe
d'accord bah voilà et c'est moi laissez
moi [ __ ] mais laissez moi sortir de
cet endroit à basile ils me donnent du
fil à retordre pourquoi prendre une
bosse on peut prendre le côté de la
bosse ce qui est nul à chier
attention politesse de sécurité est ce
que ces trucs orange protège c'est faux
[ __ ] je le savais c'est pour ça que
j'ai toujours stagne et wall un outil
qui j'ai peur de ces trucs orange à son
côté deux pays il a une tête à s'appeler
bâti ce mec
bonjour oh là là à temps il fait les
meilleurs trucs en jeu vers de profits
que vois je regarde tout droit quoi
hockey au genre de montagne j'aime pas
trop aimé cette montagne en pas se
mentir c'est quoi ça c'est pour tous les
skieurs ça regardez ce petit truc c'est
totalement pour tuer les skieurs
attention on va mourir c'est parti et
voilà qu'est ce qu'un oeuf de pâques
fait laborde elle voit passer au dessus
ou pas
oh il ya bien un petit coup sur la nuque
merci à tous je vous aime et c'est comme
ça qu'on dit klaus kinski oh oh la la
vitesse avec des vitesses david c'est sa
vitesse
ok il y avait une mini boss cachiez ne
s'est pas trompé ce qui est venu fêter
les coups de main sur cette montagne
cela vous a cédé ce qu'ils s'assurent la
faute des ce kit manière quoi j'ai un
break simon cox ici si le boss c'est
nous c'est pas les boss peu pompeux
hockey et là on attirait une piscine
avec des filles à poil on boit du thé
bougez pas trop pour des vrais gens vous
n'êtes pas les vrais shows mais qu'est
ce que c'est que ça c'est des matches
ok on va gagner sur penny souveraineté
sur le pénis a rien à gran d
exceptionnel les mannequins ont hurlé et
ancien de la gaieté tordantes
c'est quoi ça ou rien il ya une
guillotine ils veulent continuer skieurs
hockey à la figure un pur est du monde
biolo toi on m'appelle je suis comment
dieu je skie bien après aumessas et
chalets tonton ça on va goûter le ragoût
tout on brûlera un mouvement de matha
c'est bon tout en haut
c'est un membre du panthéon exploration
ça
ou quoi la neige va me semble hélas il
m'a vu un [ __ ] de fist est-ce que tu
as regardé et je finis on dira sacs de
couchage quoi allait moniteur squeeze
dans la place regardez c'est comme ça
qu'on fait comme sponsor tétouan stromae
sa grind un petit peu à l'horizontale
vous voyez c'est nul c'est comme ça
qu'on prend un télésiège dans mon pays
c'est comme ça weight au regard des eaux
usées dans la neige on ne fait plus
qu'un avec cet élément honneur et j'en
tiens compte cette vidéo sur snow plus
tard téléphone pour un jeu gratuit
j'espère que ça nous a plu c'est le cas
n'hésitez pas même temps que d'habitude
si vous voulez plus de l'info de petits
de petites techniques et astuces du
moniteur squeeze n'hésitez pas à vous
finirez en sac de couchage à la crise
2.72 portez vous bien autant de monde